cuando hablamos de las casas reales de
inmediato se nos viene a la mente la
opulencia y la acción de los grandes
protocolos protocolos que para muchos de
nosotros son desconocidos y también
generan muchas preguntas e interrogantes
que se lo vamos a trasladar a nuestro
segundo invitado el día de francisco
merino experto en casas reales y
profesor de la escuela internacional de
protocolo de madrid francisco muy buena
tarde ya para usted gracias por
acompañarnos esta mañana para nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 le
pregunto por supuesto cuál será el
protocolo el fundal de estado de la
reina isabel 2a
hola raúl buenos días a vosotros y
gracias por la invitación pues el
funeral de la reina es ave segunda va a
ser un acontecimiento un evento cargado
de muchísimo protocolo muchísimo
ceremonial y muchísima organización
detrás con horas de ensayo porque ya
sabemos que la casa real británica no
dejaron nada la estamos viendo todos los
diferentes eventos que se están
produciendo estos días los diferentes
actos que están produciendo produciendo
estos días con motivo de la muerte la
presa de sauna y el funeral que va a ser
el último gran evento en el último gran
acto de despedida a su majestad la reina
esa de segunda va a estar cargado de
muchísimo muchísimo protocolo y
muchísimo ceremonial francés que le
quiero preguntar si estos protocolos
digamos tradicionales han cambiado a lo
largo del tiempo digamos y por tratarse
de la reina habrá alguna diferencia de
otros funerales de estado que se han
llevado a cabo como por ejemplo no sé el
de su madre será especial por tratarse
de la reina isabel segunda que como
recordemos duró 70 años no menos que en
el trono
e
va a ser a ver cómo te lo explicaría
raúl
lógicamente va a ver muchas diferencias
con el de la madre la remesa la segunda
que fue en el 2002
la reina madre y la reina isabel no era
la jefa de estado era la consorte del
anterior soberano y su hija bueno pues
se le quiso dar es ese funeral de semi
estado podríamos decir porque su madre
fuera antigua consorte del rey este es
este funeral que vamos a ver de las
reuniones en segunda lógicamente estará
en
muy en sintonía podríamos decir que con
los días que estamos con el tiempo en el
que estamos viviendo el siglo 21 pero no
se van a pasar nada ni un milímetro de
todo lo que se ha marcado de todo lo que
está preparado y no hay que olvidar que
la reina isabel segunda dejó por escrito
y durante 20 años ella estuvo muy
pendiente de cómo querían que fuesen los
eventos los fastos o el funeral tras su
muerte si no vamos a encontrar grandes
momentos de modernidad por así decirlo
va a estar todo va a ser una ceremonia
cargada de mucha simbología insiste
muchísimo ceremonial no va haber nada
que esté fuera de todo lo que está
previsto y no va a haber nada que
digamos que nos deje con la sorprendido
claro este funeral de estado francisco
el que estamos hablando sería este
próximo lunes 19 de septiembre ese día
que podemos ver es decir como iniciaría
el día qué va a pasar durante el
servicio religioso que imagino que va a
haber también y cómo va a culminar para
garros también como una idea a nuestra
audiencia de que podemos ver ese día no
siguiendo los protocolos ya
tradicionales establecidos por la casa
real británica
pues me imagino que ya empezaremos o se
comenzará con el traslado del
féretro de la reina desde separación
pues viste la hora varía de westminster
es un traslado que nada es a un minuto
andando vale porque ser como el mismo
complejo vamos a me imagino que las
calles de londres del centro de londres
o de la zona donde está la varilla de
westminster estará am colapsadas de
británicos que quieren dar ese último
adiós a su a su soberana
y va a ser impresionante la cantidad de
dignatarios extranjeros
jefes de estado ex jefes de estado que
quieran dar su último adiós y rendir ese
homenaje a la reina isabel 2ª y
terminará el día con el traslado de el
féretro de la reina está segunda desde
la variedad westminster y el castillo de
windsor para ser enterrada me imagino
una imagen o no en una ceremonia íntima
una ceremonia familiar
en la capilla de san jose el windsurf
punto dónde está enterrado su padre que
es esto su madre su hermana la princesa
margarita y su marido el príncipe felipe
duque de edimburgo y me imaginé ser un
día muy memorable va a ser un día
histórico y yo creo que nos va a
sorprender lo mismo que sorprendió a
llegar si no me equivoco falla con el
traslado de la reina sí
desde ayer a edimburgo cómo están las
calles de edimburgo todas los británicos
o los escoceses mejor dicho en silencio
eso es lo que nos va lo que vamos a ver
el día del funeral y nos va a sorprender
muchísimo porque es londres am
brutal pues va a ser un momento muy
emocionante francisco también todo esto
requiere de un protocolo de seguridad
enorme también como lo estaba diciendo
de las decenas de los dignatarios
digamos que se van a ir hasta londres
para darle el último adiós a la reina
isabel segunda no también hablando de
eso y pasando digamos a otro tema el
cual sería el papel que tendrían que
tomar los integrantes de la familia real
o imagino que si hay diferencias en
ahora el rey carlos tercero también el
príncipe heredero otra u otros miembros
de la familia real digamos como este
puerto colocó más de este comportamiento
que ellos deberían tomar ante pues un
evento tan tan grande como éste
y como está dictado el protocolo nunca
mejor dicho el papel de la figura
principal en ese momento es el nuevo
jefe de estado es el soberano el rey
carlos tercero junto con su consorte de
la reina camila inmediatamente después
me imagino que están los príncipes de
gales del príncipe guillermo y kate
middleton como el heredero los nuevos
herederos al trono británico- papel
predominante también ocuparán los tres
hijos
restantes de la reina están segundo
entre la princesa real ana el duque de
york y el conde de wessex y con sus
familias nietos y demás miembros de la
familia real que no hay que olvidar que
la reina está y segunda que además
contaba con muchos de ellos son primos
con sus primos hermanos que son los
libres de los establos duques de kent y
la princesa alejandra de que en estos
días no se necesita mucho pero juega un
papel determinante dentro de la familia
real británica y la reina de segunda los
utilizaba y entiende la palabra utilizar
como miembros en activo la propia real
acudían a actos en representación de la
reina entonces ellos también tendrán un
papel predominante en esa
en el momento del funeral francisco muy
rápidamente tengo 10 segundos para esta
pregunta se puede ver a la reina isabel
segunda no
no el cemento esta mujer no dice se
puede ver